كوكب المشتري لديه ثلاثة أقمار مع محيطات
تحت قذائفهم الجليدية ، يُطلق عليهم
اسم جانيميد كاليستو ، وكان
أبناء الأرض في أوروبا فضوليين بشأن هذه
الأقمار وقدرتها على توفير حياة منزلية
لفترة طويلة ، أرسلت ناسا أول مجسات
جزئية لإلقاء نظرة فاحصة عليها في عام 1977.
كوكب المشتري  هو عملاق غازي يعني أنه
ليس له سطح ، إنه عبارة عن دوامة من
الغازات التي تتكثف في
محيط من الهيدروجين المشتعل في قلبه ، إنه
مشابه جدًا لشمسنا بهذه الطريقة ولكن
على عكس الشمس لا يدمج
ذرات الهيدروجين في  الهيليوم لتوليد الطاقة والحرارة
يعود الآن إلى مسابير ناسا الأولى التي
لاحظوها خطوطًا طويلة وبقع داكنة على
القمر ، وعادةً ما تحتوي أقمار أوروبا على
أسطح محفورة ، لكن هذه الصور تنبئ
العلماء بأنه قد يكون هناك
محيط تحت السطح الخارجي الجليدي لأوروبا
في عام 1996 كانت هذه النظرية  تم التأكيد عندما
وصلت المركبة الفضائية جاليليو إلى أوروبا ،
كان هذا أول محيط اكتشف على
كوكب آخر ، ثم في عامي 2012 و 2016
أظهر تلسكوب هابل الفضائي أن
أعمدة المياه تتصاعد من الأجزاء الأكثر دفئًا
في أوروبا لا يعرف العلماء الكثير
عن الأعمدة ولكن إذا كان يوروبا يحتوي على ماء
و  عناصر مثل الكربون والهيدروجين
يمكن أن يعني أن الحياة الميكروبية
تشكلت هناك أو حتى لا تزال موجودة
مسلحة بهذه الاحتمالية
ترسل وكالة الفضاء الأوروبية ووكالة ناسا مجسات
في أعماق نظامنا الشمسي للنظر
على وجه التحديد إلى أقمار المشتري الجليدية
أولاً هو مستكشف أقمار المشتري الجليدية.
أو عصير من عصير esa يسافر
إلى نظام المشتري مزودًا
بأحدث التقنيات لالتقاط الصور ومراقبة
المجال المغناطيسي لكوكب المشتري وأخذ
قراءات لما هو تحت
القشور الجليدية لأقمار المشتري الكبيرة لاحقًا ،
سترسل ناسا مركبة Europa Clipper للطيران
بالقرب  يحمل الاسم نفسه أكثر من 40 مرة لاستنشاق غلافه
الجوي ، حيث
سيجمع المواد من الأعمدة
لأول مرة وهذا سيعطي
العلماء فكرة أفضل إذا كانت
محيطات أوروبا قادرة على دعم الحياة ، ستجمع البعثات
البيانات التي ستهدف أيضًا إلى
جمع الأفكار حول
الأسئلة الأساسية حول  كوننا هو وجود
حياة خارج الأرض ما قد يبدو عليه
وماذا يعني ذلك لمستقبل
البشرية